je descendais les gravats je remontais
en apnée j'ai sonné les gravats je
remontant en apnée et j'ai été champion
du monde cette année là
alors Guillaume Mery vous êtes carrément
phénoménal à 14 ans vous pouvez retenir
votre respiration pendant 4 minutes
aujourd'hui c'est 7 minutes et vous
descendez à 125 mètres de profondeur
sans assistance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et puis ce jour là j'ai perdu je pense
j'aurais gagné je serais passé un autre
défi et j'ai perdu et donc je suis
rentré chez moi et j'ai dit allez il
faut que je m'entraîne pour essayer de
me battre et là j'ai découvert en fait
j'avais des capacités
à retenir votre souffle pendant 4
minutes et à l'époque le record du monde
est à 7 minutes entre 4 et 5 minutes
même hein j'étais quasiment 5 minutes
découvrir les limites du corps ça me
fascinait complètement alors en cours de
sport vous commencez à faire des
longueurs de piscine sans respirer et
parallèlement en regardant un reportage
sur France 2 vous découvrez umbaltopée
lizarabi qui est le grand champion en
fait des années 90 et là le coup de
foudre oui parce que vous saviez pas en
fait c'est ce qui vous intéressait
c'était le ciel ou la mer et là vous
découvrez que le ciel n'est pas le seul
monde inconnu finalement pourtant
j'habitais à Nice j'allais de temps en
temps avec mon père pendant l'été plongé
mais je j'imaginais pas qu'il y avait
des individus qui en avaient fait une
quête une passion l'exploration des
profondeurs vous découvrirez en fait que
la pesanteur c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut connaître sous l'eau exactement
quand j'étais jeune avant de commencer
tout ça j'étais fasciné par le monde de
l'espace
astrophysicien astronaute c'est encore
un de mes un de mes grands rêves sur
Mars pourquoi pas ouais on n'est pas
encore alors en seconde vous mettez à la
plongée et par chance en fait la Mecque
de l'apnée se trouve à Nice c'était
vraiment le centre mondial de l'apnée et
c'était en face de chez moi donc le
destin était avec moi incroyable alors
là vous allez rencontrer celui qui va
devenir votre Maître Yoda Claude Chapuis
on dit maître Yoda parce que vraiment il
nous transmettait une philosophie une
manière de fonctionner c'est pas la
technique qui était importante c'était
les valeurs oui et puis déjà après une
plongée vous vous revenez vous êtes
content d'être un peu fier de vous et
vous dit attends attends t'es gentil
d'abord tu ranges le matos quoi
exactement sa référence était karaté
kids c'est-à-dire à un moment donné
avant de vouloir être un grand champion
ils disent toujours tu prends une brosse
et tu vas frotter le bateau et comme ça
tu feras de l'apnée et c'est le début de
l'entraînement
alors la saison vous descendez à 30
mètres et là évidemment vous dites
j'étais Neil Armstrong faisant ses
premiers pas sur la Lune quoi c'est
c'est cette sensation de quitter la
surface de s'enfoncer dans le bleu de
pas voir le fond et puis à un moment
donné on touche le fond on se sent
vraiment l'alpiniste qui plante le
drapeau au sommet de l'Everest ou
Amstrong qui plante le drapeau sur la
lune on met vraiment le pied la main
dans un territoire nouveau et ça c'est
un sentiment qui est extraordinaire vous
avez 20 ans lorsque vous attaquez au
record du monde d'apnée en poids
constant c'est quoi le poids constant
c'est descendre un remonter à la seule
force musculaire donc j'utilise une
monopalme je descends je remonte donc
c'est vraiment l'homme face à la mer
sans artifice là vous descendez vous
rappelez la plaquette comme on dit la
plaquette c'est le petit témoin en fait
qui atteste qu'on est allé qu'on est
allé au fond donc c'était une symbolique
qui est très fort dans le monde de
l'apnée c'est plongé pour remonter
quelque chose voilà vous descendez à
moins 87 mètres vous êtes donc le plus
jeune recordman du monde il y a plus de
recordman du monde plus jeune jusqu'à
présent alors là
alors là vous commencez à participer à
des compétitions aux quatre coins de la
planète vous découvrez d'ailleurs le
monde à travers l'apnée et jamais pris
l'avion avant de faire de l'apnée par
exemple je considère vraiment que ma
vraie vie a commencé à partir du moment
où j'ai commencé l'apnée alors on va
parler de la préparation donc vous
entraîner tous les jours avec des petits
exercices quotidiens par exemple je te
le dis Valérie monter 5 étages sans
respirer ça c'était que j'ai habité dans
mon ancien appartement il y avait cinq
étages et je me rappelle même que tous
mes travaux parce que j'ai fait
eux-mêmes les travaux de rénovation
je les faisais en apnée je descendais
les gravats je remontais en apnée j'ai
sonné les gravages remontant en apnée et
j'ai été champion du monde cette année
là donc ça a bien marché
[Rires]
dans la journée de temps en temps vous
non voila le pince-né c'est un peu le
grigri des apnéistes alors quand vous
inspirez vous absorbez 9 litres d'air et
ensuite faites la carte c'est ça
donc en fait en fait c'est une
compression voilà je comprime l'aire
dans les poumons donc attention
important de préciser que ça ne surtout
pas faire quand on ne connaît pas faut
vraiment le faire quand on est en club
quand on connaît et donc ça permet de
prendre un ou deux litres de plus qui
nous serviront quand on profondeur alors
la descente donc vous descendez sur ce
câble avec l'assistance non pas de palme
de monopalme monopole c'est un peu comme
une queue de castor quoi
de sirène ouais c'est plus poétique
du tronc alors à moins 20 mètres vous
dites il y a plus de principe
d'Archimède c'est ça en fait ce qui nous
permet de flotter c'est le volume d'air
qu'on a dans les poumons plus on quitte
la surface plus la pression va écraser
encore et donc le volume vont diminuer
ce qui fait qu'entre 20 et 30 mètres
j'ai à peu près deux ou trois litres
d'air qui me reste dans les poumons et
donc mon corps devient lourd devient
dense et je peux arrêter de Palmer et
c'est là que début de la grande comme
une pierre je tombe voilà comme une
pierre je suis aspiré par la profondeur
on appelle ça la phase de chute libre
c'est c'est pour ça que
[Musique]
de se laisser complètement aller et il y
a le mental qui se calme de plus en plus
ça veut pas dire qu'on arrête de penser
mais c'est une forme de méditation on
est vraiment à l'intérieur du corps moi
j'appelle ça le voyage intérieur c'est à
dire que finalement il y a pas tant de
choses à voir à l'extérieur autour de
soi c'est vraiment une espèce de
d'introspection et de retour à
l'essentiel vous avez pas peur de mourir
là à ce moment-là
on est vraiment pas dans cette logique
dans cette confrontation avec avec la
mort parce que déjà je plonge jamais
seul on a une équipe de sécurité qui est
voilà qui est présente et puis je plonge
pas du jour au lendemain à 100 mètres
c'est une progression qui est très lent
donc mon corps est habitué le mental est
habitué mon physique est habitué alors
quand vous remontez il y a le risque ce
qu'on appelle l'ivresse des profondeurs
en fait c'est un archos et là vous voyez
des monstres vous voyez des bêtes
griffues poilues ricanant c'est c'est
compliqué là c'est un univers un peu
particulier la narcose c'est lié à à
l'azote qui se dissout dans le sang par
la grande profondeur et qui a un effet
narcotique c'est-à-dire c'est comme une
forme de drogue comme quand on est à
l'Afrique d'acide en fait c'est un peu
ça j'avais pris l'acide mais on m'a dit
que ça pouvait ressembler à ça
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des pensées qui
partent dans tous les sens et on
contrôle absolument plus rien la suite
c'est pour ceux qui savent pas plonger
voilà
et puis à la syncope à la syncope c'est
une petite mort en remontant vous dites
les fusibles sautent en attendant que
les organes vitaux soient touchés
alors ok donc c'est un truc très rare
mais si ça arrive il faut que quelqu'un
soit là pour nous récupérer et c'est
pour ça qu'on plonge toujours avec avec
une équipe et c'est pour ça que apnée
seul égal mort alors que la narcos c'est
à chaque fois la narcos à chaque fois
quand on plonge très profond alors avant
de se quitter dites nous le plus beau
moment où vous ayez vécu dans toute
cette série de plongée
j'ai eu la chance j'ai eu la chance de
plonger dans un endroit absolument
extraordinaire dans le monde et il ne
met plus belles plongée c'était au
Mexique dans des grottes sous-marines
dans de l'eau complètement translucide
ou finalement on
ressent pas l'idée qu'on est dans l'eau
on croit qu'on est dans l'air et dans un
décor végétal avec des arbres de l'eau
claire des troncs d'arbres morts et
finalement je n'avais pas l'impression
d'être SOUS L'EAU j'ai l'impression
d'être dans l'air mais avec une réalité
spatiale comme si j'étais dans l'espace
une expérience absolument extraordinaire
le truc
merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu